hello everyone the nord medic here and
in this video we will talk about
gonorrhea which is a sexually
transmitted disease caused by a
bacterium known as the nizeria gonorrhea
now nizaria gonorrhoeae belongs to a
group of medically important gram
negative cocky they form the coffee bean
like shape called as diplococci and they
are non-spore forming the catalyst
positive and oxidase positive
nizeriya gonorrhea is ground negative
that means if you stain nizeria
gonorrhoeae on a slide with ground stain
you get to see gram negative diplococci
this is the original microscopic picture
of that
now nizeriya gunari is a fastidious
ground negative cockkai
they are facultatively intracellular and
typically appear in pairs as diplococci
resembling the shape of coffee beans
nisaria is non-spore forming and they
lack motility
and they are obligate aerobe that means
they require oxygen to grow
now where nizeria grenoria belong in the
microbial world
now in the microbial world of free
living bacteria they can be either gram
positive or gram negative
gram negative bacteria can be gram
negative cocai or gram negative bacilli
now ground negative cocai arnis
and assinitobacter in this area we have
two important medically relevant species
known as nizaria gonorrhea and nizeria
meningitis this video is all about
nizeria gonorrhea
now nizari infection is increasing with
every passing year this graph shows the
global infection rate of nisaria
gonorrhea and as you can clearly see the
south asian countries like india
pakistan afghanistan and the entire
african
continent are the worst affected
now how these areas transmitted nesilia
transmission occurs through unprotected
sexual intercourse
having multiple sexual partners
transmission can occur from mother to
fetus during pregnancy or it may also
get transmitted during blood transfusion
now the disease caused by nesaria
gonorrhea is known as gonorrhea the
common symptoms are abdominal pain
discharge from vagina or penis
and painful urination
now the pili and outer membrane protein
2 facilitate the addition of the
gonorrhea or gonorrhea nisari that is
the gonococcus to epithelial cells
therefore make colonization possible
and then they colonize urethra cause
erythritis they colonize cervix causing
cervicitis
they colonize rectum causing anorectal
gonorrhea and sometimes conjunctiva
leading to conjunctival gonorrhea and in
children of thalmia neonatorum
miseria shows a interesting mechanism
known as the immune escape mechanism the
pili over the gonorrhea
gonococcus
resists the phagocytosis of the nizeria
gono gonorrhea and
the enzyme iga protease produced by this
gonococcus that is niseria gonorrhea
helps in cleaving the iga molecules and
thus they invade or evade the immune
system
apart from that they block the
complement system
they block th1 and th2 cell actions
and through th17 cell they invade the
neutrophils or infiltrate the
neutrophils and finally they cause lysis
of the neutrophils and come out of them
now let us see how in a laboratory setup
we can diagnose nisaria gonorrhea
now nisariya gonorrhea could be isolated
using thyromartin media now this
theomartin media is a modification of
chocolate agar media
which contains an antibiotic cocktail
the cocktail includes vancomycin to
inhibit gram positive bacteria nystatin
to inhibit fungal growth and cholesteen
to inhibit most gram negative bacteria
other than this area apart from that we
can have pcr based tests from urine
which are sensitive quick as well as
cheap
in contrast to the gram staining from
penile or vaginal discharge which are
very non-specific and are not really
efficient
now once we have diagnosed niseria
gonorrhea we have to treat you for that
now treatment includes ceftriaxone
injection the cdc recommends a single
dose of 500 mg of intravascular safety
reaction for gonorrhea now safetraxon is
a cephalosporin antibiotic and it will
stop the infection but it will not
repair any permanent damages caused by
this disease
now reinfection of gonorrhea is very
very common and re-testing after three
months of treatment is advisable
now gonorrhea shows high highly variable
antibiotic response and this variability
is due to ethnicity and geographical
distribution of the disease now
you may ask are these their
antibacterial resistance in gonorrhea
strains the answer is yes scientists
have found out gonorrhea has
progressively developed resistance to
antibiotics and that is a point of
concern
so in summary we learned about a common
sexually transmitted infection caused by
a bacteria niseria gonorrhea that is
gonorrhea now
the symptoms include genital pain and
discharge from the vagina or penis it
can occur both in men and women and in
all age groups it is not difficult to
treat but if left untreated it can lead
to more serious health problems and the
diagnosis and treatment options were
also discussed
if you enjoyed this video
please hit the like button and share
this video among your friends and peers
and if you haven't subscribed to this
channel please hit the subscribe button
and press the bell icon so that you
never miss a video from our channel to
get high quality notes and flash cards
you can follow animated biology with
urban on instagram and facebook the link
will be in the description
you can also support our channel
by monetary means by
subscribing to us on patreon
and you can also use the super thanks
icon to support our channel so that we
can continue to create high quality
educational content for free
now the super things button
you can contribute using paytm paypal or
upi
now if you wish to connect with arpan
the connection links will be given in
the description box below and for
medicine related content go and follow
the nerd medic who is a proud
collaborator of this channel until then
bye bye see you in the next one